also wanted to mention this uh from
daily wire anthropology researcher at
the University of Pittsburgh was
incredulous after her Champion female
Collegiates one of Riley Gaines pinned
him on a basic question about the
biological difference between men and
women which prompted raucous laughter
from students gains a recent University
of Kentucky graduate who tied for fifth
place with transgender identifying
swimmer Leah Thomas at the NCAA
Championship last year recently
delivered a talk at the University of
Pittsburgh about men and women sports to
a room of pact with students
Gabby Yearwood a senior lecturer at the
school's anthropology department
rejected the notion that researchers can
use skeletal evidence to determine a
deceased person's sex
so this is
you know this this is always going to be
one of one of the many kind of mic drop
rejoinders that you can have if you're
on the pro sanity side in the gender
discussion uh is is by asking look
however somebody identifies they die
they're dug up their bones are dug up by
uh by archaeologists or anthropologists
um
a hundred years from now what are those
scientists going to say about that
person's sex
and
that's definitive because they will be
able to determine based on that the sex
the gender identity won't mean anything
anymore but
this person tried to claim uh the
opposite let's watch this moment
civilization
so if you were to dig up a human two
humans and a hundred years from now both
men and women could you tell the
difference
particularly off of Bones
[Music]
I've got over 150 years of data
I'm just I'm just curious as to why I'm
being laughed at I I actually
I believe it or not I have put a lot of
research into this because I I'm not
I'm just telling you that I have
considered all viewpoints
okay he never explains how that could
possibly be the case uh well no you
can't you can't tell the sex at all but
and and
his his reasoning his defense of that is
why I have a PhD so I'm the expert so
this is what I say goes
this is the this is the kind of the Tony
fauci approach you know we've heard from
fauci that that he he is I am the
science he says I'm I'm besides if you
disagree with me you disagree with
science I represent science and uh and
this is how they all feel about
themselves they get the they get the
credentials they go and they uh get the
expensive piece of paper and now they
represent science so science is not
what it actually is which is a process
of understanding the physical world
that's all that science is it's the
process by which we come to understand
uh phenomena in the physical world
that's that side
that's what it actually is but to these
people who call themselves scientists
it's it science is uh whatever they say
it's their own it's their own Viewpoint
and they are they are uh sort of sort of
avatars for science itself
um
but this is just total nonsense I mean
he he is denying
he's denying like the entire history of
anthropology and archeology
and you can go if you want to if you
want to check the facts here you can go
on Google and just look up countless
hundreds of stories thousands of stories
of scientists digging up some ancient
Bones from centuries ago and all the
things they're able to tell about that
person
um
because as it turns out
you know your sex is
a reality that is it's not just as we
have been trying to establish it's not
just about hormones it's not about one
individual thing if you are a woman then
your entire body is you know attest to
that fact and as long as some part of
your body remains
then they'll be able to determine
yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]